happened again a pro player has been
banned mid lane match for cheating this
time at Call of Duty Challengers and
after some initial jokes about how
there's probably all a mistake or a
misunderstanding Activision reportedly
confirmed that yeah the player in
question was targeted with a cheating
ban so now the question is how much did
this affect competitive integrity and
why did it take so long to figure it out
foreign
before we get into the video I wanted to
let you know that we've just released a
new video covering our trip to Tokyo we
got to experience the Snapdragon mobile
Masters and watch the teams battle it
out in this incredible tournament we had
so much fun exploring the city and being
a part of this amazing event thanks so
much to our friends at Snapdragon Elite
Gaming for sending us to Tokyo and if
you want to keep up to speed on
everything that we got up to you can
check out the link in the description
below so on Friday a tweet from the
rotation claimed that Jimbo a member of
Team orbit had been banned mid-land
match and they included a screenshot
that showed only three members of orbit
connected they followed that up with a
short clip that appeared to show Jimbo
locked out of his account Jimbo Then
followed up with a tweet that said he'd
be unbanned and there was no reason for
the band others responded to these
initial tweets with disbelief but of
course that isn't what happened he
didn't get unbanned instead according to
Breaking Point Activision later
confirmed that the band was accurate and
that Jimbo had been caught cheating they
did not confirm exactly what kinds of
cheats were used Activision later
told.esports that it was apparently part
of a larger bandwave quote yesterday
team Ricochet executed a bandwave that
impacted over 1500 accounts across
Modern Warfare 2 and Warzone for
cheating and hacking offenses the
spokesperson said so to be clear Jimbo
was at a land when he was banned but
it's not clear that he was actually
using cheats while at the land in fact
as scump points out in his reaction to
this whole situation it might actually
be more likely that they were solely
used online I mean that is I mean
imagine being imagine being him right
now you you're cheating online you come
to the biggest Tournament of the year
with three of your teammates and then
you get them forfeited I can't imagine
the humiliation so who is this guy and
how helpful is hindsight in
understanding what happened Jimbo who
briefly went by the Alias Lao has been
around tier 2 Cod for a while and in
fact last year he actually had a short
stint with the Call of Duty leagues
Paris Legion he joined team orbit in
March 2023 alongside the rest of the
roster gravity Geo and Wiss however
earlier that month before the signing
Jimbo had been called out by Doug sensor
Martin who was the captain of Boston
breach Academy we had some issues with
the team we played in the finals we
asked them for a monitor cam link when
we went down O2 and they just refused to
give it to us they said that they would
send it to us later and I just asked
them to add a delay and send it and the
reason I'm doing that is because
a month ago the same player asked me to
monitor cam for him and I did it the
tournament in question was the seventh
cup for the North American Challenger
circuit it was played online and there
was no official tournament stream the
player in question In that clip was
Jimbo and if you're not familiar with
competitive Cod I just want to clarify
that these cups are important the prize
pools may look kind of small but the
points that they offer are how these
teams qualify for important events so
they do matter these tournaments are Run
online and during the Call of Duty Black
Ops Cold War era PC was actually adopted
as the primary competitive platform for
Call of Duty including the Call of Duty
League itself PC is optimal for a lot of
reasons but no one's gonna argue that it
doesn't make cheating easier sure it's
probably not impossible to cheat on a
console but I think it's so much easier
on PC that it's just fair to call it a
drawback so there were some questions
about whether Jimbo slash Lao was
playing suspiciously better in online
tournaments lately as some people have
noted though Jimbo has been around
longer than the online tournaments or PC
being the primary platform my co-worker
Kai you may know him from some of our
shorts content actually plays Cod
Challengers as well and in the past
during Modern Warfare 2019 he played
against Jimbo he said when he played him
back then that he was a solid respected
player but that he didn't notice
anything out of the ordinary recently
though Kai told me that in tier 2 Cod it
could be tough to know if the people
you're playing against are legit or not
it really seems like once the online
tournaments began the suspicion started
too but orbit the team that Jimbo was on
actually played a lot of games during
this period of time and some of their
recent ones were actually against omit
the team that went on to win Challengers
just a few days ago frankly there's a
lot of stuff that could have been
affected by the cheating depending on
when it happened and the frequency and
all these other factors that we just
probably will never know but if you're
asking how much damage could it have
done potentially the answer is a lot at
the same time if you're a player who
played against him it would be easy to
torment yourself with all the what-ifs
go back over the video if you still have
it saved locally it's really not worth
it at this point Jimbo has been removed
from orbit and as I mentioned the rest
of the team was disqualified but it
sounds like their qualification for
Champs remains intact which assuming
they didn't know seems like the fairest
option at this point as for Jimbo
himself well I tried to get into contact
with him but it seems like he's dropped
off the map so instead of that let's go
over some Choice tweets about a huge
month after cup number seven this guy
has the audacity to do this and then
publicly Flex on sensor if you can do
this without cheats then why are you
cheating there's even one where he's
complaining about cheaters what else do
I have to say about that there's really
nothing I can say about it I can't
imagine sending these in his position
and I'm kind of at the point where it's
all so on the nose that I'm struggling
to believe that it's real
like really it just doesn't seem real I
have reached out to Activision for
comment as well as some teammates I'll
let you know if anything develops that's
of Interest I know I just said that it
was hard to believe but it always kind
of feels surreal when you see things
like this and it's hard to understand
why somebody who's already playing at a
competitive level would just throw it
all away but when it happens this
dramatically in the middle of a land
tournament well it's going to be hard
for a lot of people to forget and For
Better or For Worse I think the name
Jimbo is going to be stuck in Call of
Duty players Minds for a while
how many of you guys are playing battle
bit right now 15 for the best
Battlefield game of your life
you know actually did you guys see that
EA is getting split up into sports and
games or whatever EA Sports is like you
guys are too poverty for us you guys
keep making bad games you guys don't
have that Gamba money with Ultimate Team